un test peu coûteux et très fiable c'est
la promesse détiennent joli ce chercheur
toulousain du cnrs qui a imaginé un
nouveau dispositif pour détecter la
présence d'anticorps chez les personnes
contaminées par le cos vide 19 le test
repose sur un procédé bien connu des
chercheurs
l'hémagglutinine à sion couramment
utilisés notamment pour la détermination
des groupes sanguins avec un geste
simple et accessible
une petite piqûre suffit pour extraire
une goutte de sang à l'instar du rituel
bien connue des diabétiques
au bout d'une heure la lecture du
résultat se fait à l'oeil nu une forme
de boutons traduit la présence
d'anticorps venu s'agglomérer à la
surface des globules rouges tandis
qu'une forme de larme indiquera que la
personne n'a pas été contaminé par le
virus
notre test il va fonctionner avec une
goutte de sang dilué qu'on va mélanger
avec un réactif unique se réactif il va
recouvrir les globules rouges de
l'échantillon convient de prélever avec
de la protéine du virus
et s'il ya dedans le ce même échantillon
des anticorps contre la protéine du
virus
ces anticorps vont lier les globules
rouges entre eux l'idée de ce projet
c'était de mettre au point un test qu'on
puisse faire sur le capot d'une voiture
au fin fond de la brousse un test hyper
simple dont il y avait ou non il n'y
avait absolument pas besoin de matériel
élaboré avant tout destiné à la
recherche ce test permettra de tester
massivement les populations pour ainsi
se faire une idée de la progression de
la pandémie
c'est un test qui devrait permettre de
suivre la progression de la pandémie
dans un premier temps dans des pays où
on n'a pas eu les moyens de tester les
gens pour savoir quelle avait été la
progression de la pandémie si d'autres
tests sont déjà disponibles
nécessite des équipements élaboré et
sont donc plus cher freinant leur
utilisation à grande échelle avec ce
nouveau test qui ne requiert aucun
matériel spécialisé le coût est estimé à
0,3 centime d'euro l'unité se faire
tester devient ainsi accessible à tous y
compris aux pays disposant de ressources
limitées